me like a vlog I Vlog I travel
um I had goats horses you have goats and
horses I was the black girl in the
mansion with all the older black people
the youngest girl in the neighborhood
with goats and animals and real big yard
and I just had fun I was just spending
my money as irresponsible as I could
because I'm a little Detroit [__] who
came into little money I ain't know what
to do with it for a minute so I bought
animals and I kind of built like hoa's
Ark in the background I like that I
built it and I was just bringing it how
many animals do you have had had how
many animals did you have
um at one point I had
six
um I had a horse I had a goat I had no
that would be five then I had a horse I
had to go I had two dogs that had a
llama that didn't even last like two
days in the house it's very illegal but
you had the Llama inside of your house
yeah I had my gold in the house in the
house and on the back outside of the
house so you would treat the goat like a
dog he was a dog we used to eat pizza
rolls together Hot Cheetos Good Vibes
with my gold but the Llama didn't last I
didn't know it was super legal to have
certain animals oh that's why I said six
I had um two Australian sugar gliders as
well rest in peace to both of them [__]
how'd they die yeah they llama kill
there what happened I was being
irresponsible
that's not good and they're gone now
they're gone then they fly off did they
Glide off to heaven
yeah they flew off to Heaven your house
must have smelled crazy amazing really
it was amazing there's no way because
they didn't live in the house like if
you saw some of my content they were
always in the back I had them tied up I
was DJing this gig like a burner store
uh on Sunset maybe like a month ago and
this lady came in it looked like Erykah
Badu walking a [__] ghost it was a
dog
it was a dog she was walking it like it
was a [__] dog it was a crazy shirt
you could train him to be dogs though my
ghost name was go tavius it was like a
little goat and this fool was just like
she kept hitting him with the milk you
know yeah and then he they're great pets
they're they're every they're good pets
so do you have any animals left I do I
have um a dog now left what kind of dog
he's a golden doodle his name is algebra
algebra he's everything to me I love it
yes yes yes it's a golden doodle that's
not like a small dog that's like a
pretty
decent size like when he stands up he's
in my face okay so you don't have like a
little pomeranian like a little no I had
actually the miniature version of him
but when me and my ex split up um it was
like this he took the dog fight over the
animals so he took the goats no he
didn't take the ghost I sold the Mansion
moved into a condo and all the animals
just one by one I was like okay I'll let
this one go okay I'll give you this who
got the horse back the lady who sold
them to me okay so she kind of hit a
lick she sold them to me and got him
right back do you so you are you like a
s escort how do you say esquitarian
esquitarian can you ride a horse yes so
you know how to get on the horse yes I
showed that on videos I used to um train
with the horses the lady who I would buy
a lot of my animals from animals from
um I would train with the horses and I
used to ride a blonde a blind horse a
blind horse oh wow that's [__]
awesome yeah that's like butt is that
awesome he doesn't crash because the way
you you know obviously because you're
you're steering him and they listen yes
and they hear so well because he can't
see so he actually can almost from
vibration feel where the fence is coming
and I used to ride a blind White Horse
wow yeah it's better than riding a blind
white man
I wouldn't mind if he if he was rich
enough there we go you know because he's
blind you could get away with so much
and he don't even know the money I'm
taking because you can't see it she
could be like uh who's here dog just the
the house cleaner
and so he has the upgraded Braille and
it's the upgrade don't forget yeah they
got Braille they know what's up did you
have you ever seen Yellowstone the show
no with Kevin Costner no makes me want
to learn how to ride horses it's a
current show with Kevin Costner yes and
he's a horse rider in the show he owns a
ranch it's like it's like a power
for white people I was about to say it's
giving super white but might be
interesting people people love it really
people love it like all people love it
Yellowstone after seeing Kevin Costner
played a role with Whitney
bodyguard I don't want to see him ride
horses you'll you'll I want him to be
like the black woman savior again in
another movie I love that energy he gave
that one great movie so horse riding
Kevin is you should you should watch it
it's really good it's some games they'd
be killing [__] and oh okay I
will watch that dude it's [__] wild
and is he doing on horses he like riding
by shootouts on horses I mean it's a
current Day show
but he's running this big Ranch in
Montana and it's just like some gangster
[__] he'd be killing fools and I'll
definitely check that out dumping their
bodies over the cliff and yeah cause
Kevin he he's not gonna be on a weak
[__] so it's like season five it's
really good and what is it on it uh see
that's where it gets complicated see
it's on Paramount plus but if you have
peacock you could watch the first four
seasons I have peacock then you can
watch I'm gonna watch when I get to the
crib yeah what's the best streaming
service in your opinion
um Netflix because I'm a documentary
person that's all I watch I love to
watch the
weirdest things on Netflix that most
people don't watch like I love hoarder I
love intervention you ever see the
Hoarders episode where the chick had a
bunch of jars of her own [__] all over
our house I did [__] I did I saw the
Hoarders where the lady was so obsessed
with animals that when they would die
she couldn't get rid of them so she kept
all of them like in these jars and boxes
hoarders gives me anxiety because I my
aunt Wendy's like that she's one of
those people so she's like a real real
hoarder she's like a white like white
trash really yeah is it is the is the
hygienes given questionable in the house
oh it's [__] up it's [__] it's [__]
up man Wendy's house is a [__] it's a
[__]
I feel like I smell it almost now I shot
a music video in her backyard
with the Ritz who's from Atlanta who's
from Gwinnett County white boy named
Ritz rapper dude big hair uh we shot a
video in Arizona and her backyard and
everyone was always asking me like bro
where'd you [__] find that place it's
a [__] up place you got shout outs I
promise my aunt's backyard I know they
fell through like oops I'm like yeah all
that [__] was not a set that's how she's
living yeah and aesthetically it worked
for the video obviously for you to go
there yes because the the video was
supposed to be a
do you ever watch Breaking Bad No with
Walter White cooking math so it's a math
Centric song okay yeah you have to go my
aunt's house is a math Centric home
I hate you right now
so I was like I got the perfect place
guys wow perfect place you ever hear
somebody describe something you kind of
like smell it almost
I picture it for some reason I feel like
I know how the house looks it's [__]
up
yeah it's [__] up I'm surprised my
Woody's been she's been sued and evicted
from every place she's ever lived in
since I've been a child wow it's [__]
I don't know how she's living where she
is now because I drove up I had to just
drop something off like a month ago
and the front yard was so [__] full
of [__] it was [__] insane I was like
she came out I said what the [__] are
you doing here
what the [__] going on what is all
this [__] it could be some personal
stuff here I am being the one making
excuses for all women doing crazy I love
it